how are you doing
okay thanks for asking how are you doing
i am well i appreciate you talking to me
about this this woman is something of a
mess but she seems so much fun at the
same time so how much absolute fun was
she to play
she was really fun i think you know
actors love getting characters who she's
sort of at sea in so many different
areas of her life and
therefore does reckless things and messy
things and
sort of reacts uh
sort of overreacts to things and so she
was really fun to play she's
she's heartless
did you know how far some of that would
go were there conversations like did you
say i'll i'll do whatever
you give me for this woman or like how
did you gain
how far things would go with something
you go for
you know but on the whole you know there
was a lot of uh you know collaboration
and discussion and i didn't have to do
anything it was a comfortable way apart
from kissing jeff which is awful but
that was fun
how hard is it to deliver lines in the
scene when someone is sucking on your
toes i mean did you i felt so bad for
her
i'm not
incredibly ticklish on my feet which is
lovely because we managed to do a lot of
takes but without repeating my pants or
anything but
um i felt so bad for her i mean she you
know she was on set for a day and that's
what she had to do and it was you know
we had to become awkward
oh hello nice to meet you and the next
thing she's swallowing my feet
she was so nice as well i felt terrible
my makeup butters and i would have been
bleaching and scrubbing and perfuming
and you know you probably chemically
poison text it just thought they're
going oh
smell a bit suck-ish you know
it's such a funny moment because she is
so like sincere and earnest about it i
just i loved that because
this person turned up oh my god she's
just
perfectly brilliant
and so kind of
lovable that um
at one point they were like you know we
have a foot double for you and i was
like okay i don't know how that's going
to work because
there's all these wide shots where it's
clearly me and they're like yes but you
know the close-ups you know
you can uh you know it's the foot drop
or whatever that means that that's got
to have two people's feet in her mouth
which is surely worth like well at least
we've broken the ice like let's just
carry on with you know
so we decided
is there a sense of freedom and fun and
playing someone who clearly doesn't
think about consequences of her actions
or
what her behavior could do even for
herself yeah and there was something
kind of i didn't know there's something
sort of she's there's something child
like about her with
certain aspects you know she's a grown
woman and she's functioning and all that
but she's got this kind of blind spots
where she sort of reacts like you think
that you know somebody much younger
would and just does things
um without really thinking them through
and that is quite fun yeah
what did you make of the relationship
between beth and tony because they have
a lot of similarities and they're sort
of stuck having to rely on each other
but they also are very different yeah
with one of them being in prison well
quite and and you know they have had
very different experiences and
backgrounds but i think
that's the nice thing is that they come
in and they they should never have met
and they probably wouldn't ever normally
be friends and
they get thrown into this situation
where i think both of them
kind of have put themselves in each
other's shoes in a way that they never
normally would
and
that's quite touching actually within
the you know the show having a lot of
dark comedy and stuff their
relationships
pretty touching and they really go at it
with each other and you know you're
never really proper friends unless
you've had some really
good arguments and recovered and they do
that
have you had conversations about
how this could continue on whether this
is a story that you could keep telling
or a character you could keep playing
and how that would work
yeah i mean the the end of it of the
show is definitely left sort of opened
that and certainly the boys uh jeff and
laurie and andre were constantly
pitching
you know season two that very heavily
featured themselves
i'm sure that there's a you know there's
definitely a
opening for that
with this character
what did you love about her from day one
were there qualities of hers that just
sort of endeared you to her from the
beginning
yeah i liked her blind spots i liked her
i liked you know actors love to get
ahold of a character who's in a kind of
crisis and she's in
sort of she's just wobbly in so many
areas of her life and i think her
identity is kind of at stake as far as
she's concerned so she's sort of hurling
herself at things um
it's that i don't know she's sort of
it's like she feels it's her last chance
for everything so she's she does a lot
of breakfast stuff and it's not really
fun being that person but i think it's
quite fun playing
it's sort of weird to just call this
a tv show because
the projects that you've done in
television have been in the streaming
space
did you make a conscious decision to
start exploring characters in a longer
format was there something that you
found appealing and interesting about
really getting to
uh to someone i don't think i've ever
really made it i mean i haven't made a
conscious decision about anything i've
sort of bumbled along
um of course i wish i was doing comedy
and then ten years later suddenly but
you know
um
i do really like that side of it um i
have to say i love movies and i love
doing movies but there is something
incredibly satisfying about having a
little bit longer to spend with a
character
um and so do you really like that aspect
of it
it's not you mentioned comedy i mean i i
feel like you're so good at the comedy
in this is that something that you would
like to do more of is that something you
try to do more of and people just don't
they see you more as like the serious
action person
uh there was a period a while ago where
i was like really
it's much more my sensibility in my
comfort zone actually than waving
machine guns to people that's a big
stretch for me um but i do think that
people really bought the machine guns
okay and uh so it took a little minute
for that to
sort of change but yeah i think i've
been quite lucky getting to
to do that sort of thing
recently
do you know what you're going to be
doing next
i just finished a movie with brian cox
called prisoner's daughter that's pretty
emotional
so we just finished that that must have
been a fun acting experience that was
great yeah i worked with him once i
played his daughter once before when i
was like 18 or so the movie that was
good and nobody saw um
but uh so yeah it was nice to get a
second answer and uh
what was it like to have jules vladimir
as a team partner because i mean this is
like her big introduction to hollywood
even though she does have training as an
actor what was it like to do scenes with
her
fantastic i mean you know
you can't get a degree in acting and
something but right now you're good you
know it's not progress everybody all the
time yeah tools wasn't hugely
experienced on a film set but like none
of us were experienced on a covered set
and so i didn't really you know jules
would say oh i've no idea what this is
what that is but she's very poised and
she's very
um she's very good so it didn't feel
like oh here's this brand new person who
doesn't know what they're doing so like
here's this really fantastic characters
you might really like
so
it was sad that she didn't get to you
know have the experience that most of us
had on our first jobs where you get to
go out and hang out and everyone you
know kind of takes you under their wings
socially as well like she didn't really
get to do that i think that must have
been really rough but
we wouldn't know it's her first job at
all
was it challenging to get past the
distraction of being on a coveted set
having everybody in masks and and having
all of that going on while you're trying
to
do a scene
and you know in canada the cover test is
very deeply down the throat so
every single day there was a kind of you
know gagging
um which is how i generally start my
work day sort of gagging
anyway and uh and then yeah there's sort
of shock of seeing people's chins that
you've been working with for
uh five or six months and that's not
what you're expecting at all and people
have wild moustaches and beards that you
didn't know you know it's all it's all
very exciting well i appreciate you
talking to me about this i'm absolutely
loving this character i'm excited to
take the rest of her journey with her
it gets it gets wild so
thank you so much